[Music]
alright guys the world is crazy
people are dying yeah
certain communities are I think are
getting hit harder than others yeah yeah
within the states and it's this is just
now it's kind of like like Costco
members like that community the most
valuable people oh yeah I mean I don't
know if there's a study on that specific
how would suck because they're the ones
shopping the hardest and hustle they're
like penny buyers and aromatic buyers
are getting sick the most that's where
everyone has a triple-a car dude my
membership renewal just came I should
probably not renew it you should because
you're still driving yeah but if they're
getting hit hard though who the triple-a
members I'd rather have a flat tire than
[ __ ] call and cancel your crippling I
know if that's the case well who's the
crew before I cancel my membership yeah
so the in in the states there is a study
now and that's coming out and they're
saying the black demographic the black
population in the states is getting hit
the hardest in terms of deaths you know
it's crazy because I remember how I was
reading some [ __ ] about like there was
this not conspiracy but it was like why
isn't Africa or like the black
communities getting hit with this but it
was make mainly like Asian and white
yeah my corker was talking about it
because she was like she came into
office prior to us getting quarantine
she was like yo man don't block Twitter
and that's just wild and all like there
was actually a lot of like like black
media like you know how there's a lot of
black radio show us stuff like that they
were she human thing on there at the
beginning like December January they're
like yeah black people don't get Korona
yeah and then they were like what are
you talking about why and they're like
it's because of our melanin don't you
know yeah and they're like alright that
was one of the theories that she was
like throwing out she's like yeah people
are saying that the melanin like like um
her co-worker black yeah she was like
yeah okay okay I saw what she is things
on it and why like some people were
getting mad when though it's pretty
online yeah is because there was a lot
of people coming out like it seemed like
the way that people would say on news is
like that's [ __ ] out the black people
are negate why aren't they getting any
kind
exactly in a sense it's like you kind of
it's not that fair yeah they have a lot
of stuff going on there that we don't
get like sickle cell and all that stuff
and I think it's fair if they didn't get
it cuz yeah you know it's like but
exactly it's not equal when it comes to
disease there's a [ __ ] ton out in Africa
that sucks yeah that was like the
counter-argument on that Twitter throw
that micro requesting cuz like a lot of
you were like what like what people
experienced like a lot of shitty things
like why can't we just have this one
thing yeah what the viruses we carry why
is barking why is it hitting their
community more than others in America in
America I don't know here's some stats
real quick though so in in Michigan and
this study is to is done in Michigan and
we all know Detroit
I think the Troy is 80% black according
this article also then it's not a
minority group there hmm
oh it's their community but it's not a
minority group I was thinking never mind
well he's think of all of Michigan yeah
yeah yeah yeah all in Michigan the
population of the black people is 14
percent 14 percent okay so that's about
to blow detroit itself is 80% 80% detail
a lot of those black people with Luhan
they're like what visitors maybe maybe
they were trying to get some really good
Chinese food but so 14% small number
right but 33% of coronavirus cases and
41% of deaths in the black community in
Michigan it is is black
oh that's very high high yeah it seems
like every city the death rate is double
the population black people compared to
so 30% the death rate is like 60 70 %
all the ways they're not getting the
like proper help in the health care and
there's a lot of diabetes yes if you're
like pre-diabetic diabetic or a
pre-existing respiratory disease asthma
yeah any of those then you're way more
prone to getting Ronis it's like a
different kind of only getting it or
being heavily affected by it
have we are more prone to getting it and
then also have the affected by it now
the different of racism now to where
experts have to go on TV because people
are like yeah black people just will get
Korona easier and it's like that's
what's our like no no it's it's social
economic issues that are affecting them
and that's the reason why they're there
dad [ __ ] idiot on the news that's
saying black people get Corona no it's
like a public opinion cuz they're like
oh they're time two and two together
right they're like why are bad people
dying twice as much even though the
populations half and we gotta figure out
that was more susceptible just because
of that hey I hate the identity politics
are tied to some of this yeah so the
experts are like that's a race yeah like
how they go to race before science yeah
so in this it was is with some
statistics here african-americans are
twice as likely to get heart disease
strokes and diabetes than Caucasians
it's probably the diet the diet yeah so
it's like there's more of a health thing
I guess yeah and then I guess
statistically african-americans
I guess health is not and I guess they
suffer from more heart failure asthma
and hypertension these are all
statistics I know from from hospitals
and said I'm with you I learned the same
stats when I was in college about
studying different culture groups and
because like what what they're saying
specifically is that african-americans
like new immigrants from Africa don't
have the same dietary like culture of a
minute it's a different culture like
blacks in America that's been here for a
while right it's different so then like
they might eat more vegetables are more
like mashed up beans all the time or
it's more closer to vegan diet or
whatever so like their health was
completely different even though
genetically they're more obviously of
the same race you know the food is good
though I wonder if the studies the same
for the south because like that that
food like fried chicken and all that I
mean like I could wheat that [ __ ] too
right yeah so are they just as healthy I
bow man cuz lack people fried chicken
compare the white people fried chicken
is different as a difference well sure
if you look at those communities where
it's like equal and they're eating the
same food you're gonna see a higher
level of like diabetes it's more about
like a communities right but those
communities happen to be a higher
percentage black yeah and plus they're
also more densely populated so it's
probably more rapid than like this is
Mississippi like the fattest state in
the US or some [ __ ] sounds like it could
yeah Anders that are there any
statistics about how many sumo wrestlers
have died from Ronis yeah cuz they're
pretty heavy too
healthy healthy not healthy I mean
strong and and yeah athletic and they
burn a lot of calories a lot of veggies
and rice and things like that and that's
so much like saturated fats and whatnot
from like animals but they do die
younger than other typical Japanese
people you because typical Japanese
people struggle live to a hundred so
yeah they're 70 it's like thirty years
too short buddy
oh man my grandma died at 99 yeah we
might grab a pasta a hundred and
something that's it like 97 97 or
something yeah yeah
that's why would I when I went to the
sound like radio station I had to say
the funeral always kind of like when I
was crying I was like what do you expect
obviously it's I was like was it a
surprise like she was gonna go oh damn
how well did you guys want to live - I
go I think about it depends on my heart
yeah polity of life if I have a shitty
health right now am i I'm just like in
the bed all day all night kill me now
bro [ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] come back I
believe a reincarnation what you wanna
reincarnate as a dandelion have a kid
pick me up and go blowing that's like
the most
your first ripped off and then you're
getting it pull that's a violent death
is getting pulled out that's like
separate from your legs how do you get
rid of these weeds they got a weed
whacker just tearing you hard oh [ __ ] I
didn't think it through
I think I'm mystic optimistically about
this and like I really imagine a kid
pulling you out and is just blowing on
you and making a whole bunch of wishes
and you're gonna make those wishes come
true yeah just think so they don't or
anyway I'm bleep load no it's a kid
it was a hot girl if it's a hot girl
she's on a picnic date and she's like
look it's a bad girl and she's like and
I'm like I gotta blow it again my
afterlife yeah we're saying nothing oh
I'm saying that people with lawns like
hate that [ __ ] hate kids blowing on
lands cuz it makes more it's like yeah
it's like Oh cuz our weeds out on one
and about 20 of them pop up but that's
their their sole purpose that's what
happens with the wind
anyways yeah exactly that's why it is so
much worse when my kids pick it up cuz
and now it's spreading really fast you
pick up ten miles in a hundred grow up
that's true I probably saw you talking
about flowers they always talk about the
flowers okay we always talk about a hoop
but holes and flowers flowers yes last
time was all about eating [ __ ] true I
got hungry
flowers and [ __ ] anything this sucks
man um I I feel like okay so usually you
know when there's virus or things like
in the past it hits the weakest humans
or just people that are the unhealthiest
or whatever right but then now a lot of
this unhealthiness is self induced you
don't mean like so humans we have enough
food now or at least in America right
versus like and then when we had the
Great Depression people were [ __ ]
hungry as hell now we have too much food
we're the poor population they can't
they can't afford healthy food but they
can afford food and then there's a lot
of unhealthy [ __ ] and then if the
opposite is happening is we have a poor
population that's bad versus like in in
in all of history poor populations were
always hungry right that was kind of
wealthy yeah what's also crazy is I was
on the explore page and then Jermaine
Dupri popped up and he was talking about
the Ronis and then he was some you know
this is I just was referring to a black
community and this when I first heard
that the black community hit kind of
hard it was explaining about like so I
got to get some real authority on here
so join me at seven o'clock imma have
Diddy on here are you gonna talk about
the rawness and like why the [ __ ] do
people always look to celebrities for
answers that's the one part I don't
understand the whole bad boy can we
assembled from the 90s to come out cuz
the road of crisis God is back together
we're resurrecting biggie we're gonna
have a whole concert just it's kind of
like a system that feeds into itself
though because even if you're already up
there you know that the public will
listen to your buddy Diddy over here
more than a daughter but they don't know
anything like people ask me I'm like go
ask your [ __ ] doctor did I don't know
[ __ ] anything go have dr. mic or
somebody on your Channel yeah have you
seen the posts that keV has been onstage
yeah yeah keV on stage he gets these
like sermons right like at the black
church and then they're singing songs
about the Rona say there's like Corona
no no no or some [ __ ] like it'll come up
with catchy
yeah it sucks when you get especially in
that time where it's like people are
looking to lay the church for answers
yeah and they're the ones I like
yeah just come here like and they're
profiting off it right close to each
other I've been seeing a lot especially
like I mean I think it's everywhere in
the Korean because I have a lot of
Korean friends I guess but it's there
all the churches are all in line people
just like watching in and they're like
hardcore like religious but there are a
lot being safe trying to do it like
properly Wow spotty yeah it's crazy
times and everyone is being affected by
this our heart goes out to anyone that
is being affected and stay safe
everybody
[Music]